[Music]  [Music]  David said how to feel it like I'm going  crazy you talk [ __ ] and telling me how I  ain't ready for you right now  i'ma make it eat your words  ooh baby baby said I can tell that you a  little faded now I'm about to put it  down hold it oh baby screaming telling  me right there shaky special a little  bite I don't think your asses in your  back don't stop  [Music]  I'm a little worst kill you in trouble  there perfect piece to a puzzle oh but  some shift W what it was  now watch o me Sparkle thought this was  a game hustle that blanket but uh your  Kitty's been testing me and I partook  this won't you put it on your ass don't  stop  [Music]  when  [Music]  it's about another goofy  really so just call me back man  [Music]